everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we're going to be
going over a very strong defense from
black and that's the nimzo-indian
defense and you'll see it played at all
levels even hygiene levels pretty much
all teams play this and it starts out
with pollen d 4 e 6 c4 Knight to f6
development move and Knight to c3
development move followed by Bishop to
b4 pinning down this Knight to the King
on e1 now Black's really saying that he
doesn't mind giving up his bishop pair
exchanging his Bishop for this knight on
c3 in hopes that White will have a
double pawn here on the C file and he
can exploit that at the same time black
really wants to start adding his
defences of this e4 square he already
has his night here on f6 attacking the
e4 square at the same time if he wants
to he can fee and Cato as bishop to this
b 7 squared which you'll see in some of
our variations putting more pressure on
this
efore square and by pinning down this
night here on c3 to the King we're
taking away one of the defenders of the
e4 squared because as you'll see this is
kind of a passive defenses we don't move
a lot of our pieces and pawns past this
sixth rank here but we really don't want
to give up all the center control to
white we really want to focus on the
light squares in particular most of the
variations and more importantly focus on
this e4 square now sometimes we will be
attacking but more than like we really
want to counter-attack eventually in the
center here so the first variation that
we are going to look at is the
Rubinstein system and that is pawn to e3
and there's three main system its e3
you'll see is the Rubenstein and then
you'll see the classical which is Queen
to c2 and then last this Kasparov switch
is Knight to f3 you can't really argue
with Kasparov even though his opening is
not really most common most common that
you will see is the pawn to e3 so we're
going to go over some of the variations
you will see in the Rubenstein variation
the main line continues with black
castling on the kingside again a lot of
these variations black is really content
just building up his own defense and
then he's going to later on try to
counter in the center and then depending
on where white moves if he wants to
attack on the king or the queen side but
from here why it's going to continue
bringing his Bishop to d3 nice
development move here and then we're
going to start to attack we're trying to
attack this pawn or excuse me the square
I'm efore but at the same time we're
attacking this pawn on c4 and white may
continue simple development move Knight
to f3 freeing the way for his King to
castle on the King side and from here
we're going to bring our pawn to c5 very
common mood that you'll see here at the
same time we're trying to counter-attack
this Center right now White has a very
strong center with three pawns here in
the middle at the same time he has three
minor pieces all on the third right rank
here trying to by force inter control so
this move of c5 here is really trying to
just break up the center control in this
case really trying to knock off this d4
pawn here now from here white may
continue castle on the King side King
side safety I was important and from
here we can take on c4 and then after he
takes with his bishop on c4 then we have
a few options but as you can see here
White's really maintained his sooner
control at the same time black has very
solid defense here around his King at
the same time we do have a lot of
counter play we can bring our knight to
c6 if we want to we can also bring our
Knight to d7 if we want to and again we
can always capture here on c3 we can
capture here on d4 so we definitely do
have a lot of options in the mainline my
personal favorite variation in the
Rubinstein system is pawn to c5 and this
puts a lot of pressure right away on the
D pawn now again there are many many
different variations so not going to go
over you know 10 20 minutes on every
single variation but I do want to let
you know some of the common ones and
also kind of what I like to play myself
and how it kind of works for me and I
feel like pawn to c5 is probably one of
the more aggressive plays for black it
puts a lot of pressure right away again
on this d4 pawn and at the same time if
he does take then we have two options
here we can bring our nine to eight six
and eventually take or we can take with
our bishop or at the same time we can
take with our bishop on c3 and then he's
going to have triple pawns here so you
may not even see him take with this pawn
right away but again we are putting a
lot of pressure on this d4 pawn the last
option that you do have in the
Rubinstein system is pawn to b6 and this
is actually what Bobby Fischer preferred
Bobby Fischer is a better player than I
am so I would definitely say listen to
him and try it out if you want but from
here a lot of times you either see
Knight come to e2 or you may even see
Bishop come to d3 more times than not
though you will see the knight come to
e2 trying to alleviate pressure on this
night here on c3 and if we do take
instead of having double pawns you can
always recapture with this knight here
and there's two variations from here
Bobby Fischer's variation is actually
Bishop to a6 if we can ever get rid of
this pawn here which we can push forward
with our pawn here on d5 to get rid of
this pawn here we can exchange our light
square Bishop if we chose to and second
of all there's another variation besides
this a6 and that's the American
variation and that is from here we're
going to bring our Knight to e4 putting
a lot of pressure on this night here on
c3 we're going to exchange both of our
pieces our night and our Bishop here on
c3 and then we're going to bring our
pawn our F pawn to f5 and this is a very
very aggressive defense from black
because we're still again trying to put
a lot of pressure on this central e4
square that we talked about earlier then
we can castle on the King side still and
we'll have this semi open F file if we
can get off this pawn on f5 but as you
can see this is very aggressive you're
really trying to put a lot of pressure
on the center especially this e4 square
so you definitely do have a lot of
options in the Rubinstein system one of
the variations is getting a lot of
traction in chess is Queen to c2 a lot
of white players when they face the
nimzo-indian defense which is very
common they really don't want to have
these double pawns on the C file so a
lot of times instead of opting for the
Rubinstein with pawn to e3
they'll just instead play Queen to c2
basically saying if you want to trade
off your Bishop pair that's fine but I'm
just going to recapture with my Queen
here on c3
now there are a few main lines that you
will see the most common is castling on
the King side and then pawn to a3 really
trying to test black and see what
they're going to do if he's going to
capture and give up his bishop here do
something else from here black is going
to capture he's going to be very passive
if he tries to bring his bishop back to
a5 and then
white can continue to push his pawns
down the board and eventually force
black to lose material as he's going to
lose his bishop here now from here why
it's obviously going to take as we
talked about before with this Queen on
c3 then we're going to bring our pawn to
b6 getting right into P and headed with
our Bishop to b7 and start to attack
this Square on e4 here now from here
black can bring his Bishop down to g5
pinning our knight down to our queen as
you can see here already White's pieces
are a little bit more active as far as
ours have not gone past the six rank but
at the same time this complete side his
King side is completely underdeveloped
and most of ours we already have King
side safety we're already Castle down
the king side at the same time we can
develop our LightSquared Bishop pretty
easily we can get our knight developed
pretty easily with Knight to c6 so black
does have a lot of options here and this
is kind of a common theme that you will
see is black really tries to play a
little passive early on tries to build
up a nice defense and then counters
later on the next variation that you
will see and again this we saw this in
the Rubinstein but it's pawn to c5 and
this is again my favorite if I do face
this Queen to c2 because it really right
away puts a lot of pressure on this b4
pawn there's not a lot white can do to
hold on to both his epon and his deep on
here now if he does capture we do have a
few options like before we can bring our
knight to a6 and capture with our knight
we can ride away capture with our bishop
or if we want to we can capture this
night here on c3 and then bring our
knight to a6 and capture on c5 so we
definitely do have a lot of options I
prefer just to bring our Bishop down to
c5 and from here we can develop our
Knight to c6 if we want to we can castle
on the King side and I feel like this
has a very good game for black in store
the laceration that you will see is the
kasparov and that's Knight to f3 now
it's not played very often so I'm not
going to spend too much time on it but
from here just keep in mind that if you
do see it you really want to start
counter attacking the center right away
and you can do that by pawn to d5 again
putting a lot of pressure on this
efore square at the same time really
challenging white and the center here we
can eventually as we talked about before
bring your pawn to c5 then we can start
to develop other minor pieces castle on
the King side but right away we're
basically saying you know we're going to
try to attack this Center control that
White's already build up so if you do
see this knight come to f3 don't panic
but you won't see it as much as the
Rubinstein or the classical so hope you
guys enjoy this video on the
nimzo-indian defense if you haven't
subscribed already please do that and I
will see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching